welcome back it's interesting to see
what conservatives are conservatives who
think who really believe that they are
they are above the fray or fancied
themselves to be intellectuals are those
people who really believe that there's
some merit in conservative ideology it's
been fascinating to watch how they
contort themselves in this era of Trump
when Trump is the personification of
modern-day conservatism and he is the
leader of a Republican Party that is
fully behind him when it comes to policy
they may not like his demeanor but when
it comes to policy Republicans are 100%
behind him and so so goes the same for
former Speaker of the House John Boehner
he had some comments last week on the
state of the Republican Party underneath
Trump and then today or yesterday rather
George Will has some comments a
conservative commentator and author
he writes extensively on conservative
ideology but this is what he had to say
about conservatism underneath Donald
Trump today it's become a cult it's
become a cultures because of an absence
of ideas because they've jettisoned the
ideas for years decades all the 20th
century on this conservative said we're
for free trade Trump said by the way
you're not anymore and they said okay
we're not for free trade anymore or they
pretend to be what I've done with this
book is trying to say there isn't
conservatism has an enormous Lea long
and distinguished pedigree of ideas it
has a momentum into the future given by
these ideas and they did not go away and
they have not been refuted by the 45th
President so I mean it is fascinating to
watch how they contort themselves right
to try to distinguish conservatism from
republicanism more from trumpism they
tried to make it seem as though they're
totally unique in different things and I
actually want to pull up what george
will's said i wanna i want to read it as
a quote just for emphasis sake he said
quote in terms of the republican party
he said quote it has become a cult
because of an absence of ideas
because they have jettisoned the ideas
for years decades all of the 20th
century almost conservatives said that
we were for free trade Trump said by the
way you're not anymore and they said
okay we're not for free trade anymore or
they pretend to be you know free trade
is actually the least of conservatives
worries right now in terms of how Donald
Trump is betraying their so-called
ideology right Donald Trump as I've said
many times before Donald Trump is
actually an internationalist he's just
operating with these these this this
situation regarding the leave trade war
with with China and the tariffs that's
really Eagle driven that's not really
based on any economic ideology so I
would actually put that aside and and
honestly look at Donald Trump he is a
representation of the Republican Party
it's not that the Republicans have
jettisoned their ideas all of a sudden
because of Trump it's really because
well the ideas and the ideology of
conservatism inevitably led to the rise
of Donald Trump so it's impossible for
conservatives to try to separate
themselves from who Donald Trump is and
what he does because number one they led
to this what they have they comported
themselves what they did to Barack Obama
how they and not just Barack Obama right
you could trace this all the way back to
to Newt Gingrich when he was Speaker of
the House underneath Bill Clinton and
the scorched earth policies that Newt
Gingrich implemented it he took he
jettisoned the ideas and made
Republicans willing and taught them in
fact enforced it and Speaker of the
House such that they would it did not
matter what they believed what they
would do under any circumstance was be
in opposition
100% opposition no matter what that
Democrat is fighting for even if that
Democrat is fighting for a conservative
idea like free trade if if the Democrat
is fighting for a conservative idea like
the Affordable Care Act which was a
conservative idea
conservatives taught themselves and
discipline themselves to oppose
Democrats at every stop so that they
could always find a way to gang gain
political power so George Will's
comments are you know they feel good
right they sound good but in reality
every step of the way
Republicans in conservatism have paved
the way for Donald Trump the same
sentiment was given by John Boehner last
week and he said this in at an event he
said quote there is no Republican Party
there's a Trump party the Republican
Party is kind of taking a nap somewhere
well you know John Boehner you helped
create this situation you played the
same type of politics that Newt Gingrich
played played when he was Speaker of the
House right your opposition to down to
Barack Obama every step of the way your
opposition to him not just because a
rather let me let me restate that your
opposition to him simply because he was
a Democrat right your attempt to help
your how many times how many times did
the House of Representatives underneath
the direction of John Bainer try to
overturn and to get rid of the
Affordable Care Act when the Affordable
Care Act was 100 percent a conservative
idea based on quote-unquote free markets
so this is disingenuous at best its
revisionist at worst they're trying to
separate themselves from Donald Trump
when they paved the way that hyper
partisanship that the where do you go
here's here's the question where do you
go when your politics have become so
divisive and so overly simplified that
your entire existence is predicated on
AAPIs on the opposition to your opponent
it doesn't matter what your opponent
does your entire life as a Republican
for the last 3040 years has been 100%
opposition to the Democratic Party and
the Democratic Party in their infinite
wisdom Reid sarcasm right try to try to
appeal to Republicans they're still
trying to do it they're trying to
negotiate with Republicans by moving
further and further and further to the
right but no matter how far
to the right Democrats move Republicans
have a very simple strategy opposition
at all cost and because of that their
politics have become so hyper partisan
there was nothing left to do to
distinguish yourself from anyone else
except this American nativism this
xenophobia this all-out bigotry right to
appeal to American bigotry that Donald
Trump encapsulate slike this is who he
is this is the only thing that
distinguishes him in a sea of
Republicans who are also hyper partisan
that they don't have sense betrayed
everything that they believed that that
that's the point I like simply because
they have the strategy of by any means
necessary no matter what it cost no
matter what we have to betray we will
betray our own conservatives and we will
betray the free markets we'll do
anything we have to do to stand in
opposition to the Democratic Party
because that is our strategy to obtain
power and when everyone is that hyper
partisan then there's nothing any
candidate Republican candidate could
have done to really distinguish
themselves from the other intradermal
Trump who says well there is that one
last thing you guys have the appearance
of decorum
right I don't even want the appearance
of decorum because you know what there's
a lot of Americans who believe in all
the same crap that Republicans believe
in but they have just been waiting for
someone to come and say all of the
things that are said in private with
Republicans Donald Trump distinguished
himself he's just as partisan he's just
as conservative and he distinguished
himself by being this open bigot that so
many people America in America find
found attractive today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business
almost an endless list and whether
you're trying to get ahead in your
career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]